sevens don't really exist we don't
really rate people sevens um eights or
higher is like Hollywood you know
traditional modeling contracts not not
what they have today now we got Sierra
you know this is one of the number one
women
that I get on the show and it's
interesting because when I would ask men
celebrity crushes I just noticed a trend
of guys only naming celebrity crushes
from 10 15 20 years ago and I would
never hear guys mention any Chick
from today not really okay so now we
have the celebrities of today and I
would rate most of these chicks
adjustable sixes I would say they're all
above average they're all cute none of
them are the stunningly beautiful women
we had of 10 20 years ago they're not
Jennifer Aniston they're not Angelina
Jolie